اا فرنسيه
علاقات موجوده مع فرنسا ايضا بالدوله
صديقه الى محاله ونذاكر ساركوزي هو اليوم
الحلقات قطع
الفرنسيين ردوا عليه
المساله جاءت في نوفمبر في اخر نوفمبر لما
خرجت حكايه ويكيليكس يعني حسابي فقط
والمفترضين همم
الى السعوديه
قال انا اودع عائلتي الذهاب الى العمره
عندما جاءت همم الامن تسلم القصر الى
اخرها بعد احداث همم نظرته بقيت على
المكتب همم يعني حاسوب صغير على مكتبي
يعني
هذا هذا الغريب في الامر لكن على كل هي
ذهابه الى السعوديه مع عائلته
شو يعني ماذا تريد ان تقول يعني
قصرا
اخذ على الطائره
الاول
قال لم اذهب الى نفسي
لا اضيفه على هذا شيء تمام حتى يعني
فقط نفتح قوس يعني شكر للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه التي استقبل الرئيس
واكرمته
وقدرته وجوده
همم ام مكنت من ان يدفن في البقيع ذلك
المكان الذي يحبه كل المسلمين كل المسلمين
وبالتالي اجدد شكري لهم وللعائل المالكه
وهذا امر نعتبره همم جزء من كرم الضيافه
وهمم
العزه التي تجمع امهتنا